Hey, guys are upon on the other side horn field turn beige and waves to Hey guys, it's Joel, and welcome to the fish watch the forest, to fill the stage within it. Guys, it's Joel and welcome to the Tapu Therapy Therapy Collective podcast. Today, we're going to be following up on the Mirror World series and talking about the kaleidoscope. How do you know that the color blue that you see is the same as the color blue that I see? I mean, we both call it blue and we point at the sky and we use the same word.
大家好，我是乔尔，欢迎收听《Taproot Therapy Collective》播客。今天，我们将继续“镜像世界”系列，聊聊万花筒。你怎么知道你看到的蓝色和我看到的蓝色是一样的呢？我的意思是，我们都管它叫蓝色，我们都指着天空，用的也是同一个词。
But we actually share the same subjective experience of that wavelength of light. Well, some people don't. They might be colorblind and see it as a different color. We're just assuming that because the word matches, the experience matches too. This is an old philosophical puzzle, and it used to be the kind of thing that you discussed in a dorm room at 2 a.m. And then you forgot because it didn't seem to matter. And it didn't. Or did it?
但我们真的共享了对那种光波的相同主观体验吗？嗯，有些人并没有。他们可能是色盲，看到的颜色可能不同。我们只是因为词汇一致，就假设体验也一致。这是一个古老的哲学难题，过去这通常是凌晨两点在宿舍里讨论的话题。然后你就忘了，因为它似乎无关紧要。确实如此。或者说，真的无关紧要吗？
We could all agree that the sky was blue, whatever blue meant to each of us privately. And so the word worked. And communication happened and life went on. But something has changed. And that old philosophical puzzle has become the defining problem of our time. You know, we are now living through this crisis where people use the same words and they mean completely different things. You know, freedom or Christian or a lot of big, important words. They don't mean what you mean.
我们都可以同意天空是蓝色的，无论蓝色对我们每个人私下里意味着什么。所以这个词起作用了。交流发生了，生活继续了。但有些事情已经改变了。那个古老的哲学难题已经成为我们这个时代的决定性问题。你知道，我们现在正经历着一场危机，人们使用相同的词汇，却表达着完全不同的含义。你知道，自由、基督徒，或者许多宏大、重要的词汇。它们的意思和你理解的并不一样。
The same sentence can be a factual claim and a tribal signal and a joke and a weapon all at once. you know, so you can look crazy if you point some of these things out because language has become so doubly and triply coded, you know, like computer code. So, well, you can spend an hour arguing of someone online and realize at the end that you weren't even having the same conversation. Or maybe you don't, and that changes the way that you see people. You know, this is a big idea, but it's not just frustrating and sort of breaking politics and relationships. And I would argue the mind, you know, this is a therapy podcast, I guess. I want to try and explain something that's happening. You know, why communication feels so impossible now,
同一句话可以同时是事实陈述、部落信号、笑话和武器。你知道，如果你指出其中一些事情，你看起来会很疯狂，因为语言已经变得像计算机代码一样，有了双重甚至三重编码。所以，你可以在网上和某人争论一个小时，最后才意识到你们根本不在同一个频道上。或者你没意识到，这改变了你看待他人的方式。你知道，这是一个宏大的想法，但它不仅令人沮丧，还在破坏政治和人际关系。我认为，它甚至在破坏思维。你知道，这大概是一个心理治疗播客。我想试着解释一下正在发生的事情。你知道，为什么现在的交流感觉如此不可能，
the way facts don't matter. And I don't mean, you know, alternative facts, facts don't matter. I mean, the actual facts that we think are factual do not affect us anymore in the way that we think they do, our facts, not somebody else, having the wrong ones. You know, we feel both simultaneously hyper-connected and utterly alone. And I want to suggest that what we're experiencing is not just confusion. It's actually a transition or an attempt. to make a transition.
为什么事实变得无关紧要。我指的不是“另类事实”，而是事实本身不再重要。我的意思是，我们认为真实的事实，不再像我们预想的那样影响我们了，我说的是我们的事实，而不是别人那些错误的事实。你知道，我们感到既高度互联又极其孤独。我想指出的是，我们所经历的不仅仅是困惑。这实际上是一种过渡，或者说是一次尝试。一次过渡的尝试。
You know, it's a painful disorienting passage between two different ways of being human. And that doesn't mean that one is bad. It means that all of us are doing both at the same time. This is not an us against them podcast. It's, I don't know if you want to be an English major and make me pick with the tension as I think it's an us against us podcast.
你知道，这是两种不同的人类存在方式之间痛苦而令人迷失的过渡。这并不意味着其中一种是坏的。这意味着我们所有人都在同时进行这两种方式。这不是一个“我们对抗他们”的播客。我不知道你是否想成为一名英语专业学生，让我来纠结其中的张力，但我认为这是一个“我们对抗我们”的播客。
You know, the theorist in me wants to call this the metamodern condition. But I'm going to call it the digital dream time. to keep it in line with Jungian psychology. I think that understanding it is the only way that we're going to survive what's coming. And the first part is this kind of fusion of the brain. You know, at Taproot where I work, you know, we have through peak neuroscience, Jay Michelani and Deanna Pizarro and Rachel and a couple other people,
你知道，我内心里的理论家想把这称为“元现代状况”。但我打算称之为“数字梦境时间”，以符合荣格心理学。我认为理解这一点是我们度过即将到来的一切的唯一途径。而第一部分就是这种大脑的融合。你知道，在我工作的Taproot，我们有通过峰值神经科学，杰伊·米歇拉尼、迪安娜·皮萨罗、瑞秋和其他几个人，
you know, we have this quantitative electroencephalography, You know, QEG. And it's brain mapping that, you know, is used to treat autism or dopamine disorders and anxiety, different things by making different parts of the brain send information either a different way or talk more, especially more quickly, or talk less. Don't talk as much. Talk to another part. You know, and it's this way of measuring electrical activity in the brain, wavelengths.
你知道，我们有这种定量脑电图，也就是QEG。这是一种大脑映射技术，用于治疗自闭症、多巴胺紊乱和焦虑症等，通过让大脑的不同部位以不同的方式发送信息，或者交流得更多、更快，或者交流得更少。别说那么多。和另一个部位交流。你知道，这是一种测量大脑电活动、波长的方法。
How fast the neurons moving and what is it sending information to it. and seeing which areas are, you know, overactive or underactive and identifying patterns that might contribute to symptoms. So you can sort of bypass me. I don't have to listen to you and then diagnose you. Your brain can just tell the machine exactly what it's doing, and then the engineers can tell that to you. And so I once asked, you know, when Jay and Deanna were joining,
测量神经元移动的速度，以及它在向哪里发送信息。观察哪些区域过度活跃或活跃不足，并识别可能导致症状的模式。这样你就可以绕过我。我不必听你说话然后为你诊断。你的大脑可以直接告诉机器它在做什么，然后工程师可以把这些告诉你。所以我曾经问过，你知道，当杰伊和迪安娜加入时，
and luckily they have a good sense of humor. It's kind of hard to work with me if you don't. I was asking Jay, because he was talking about how the machine worked on the idea that the brain would mimic frequencies. That when the nerve, the cap that does the treatment starts to put out a frequency really strongly, the neuron will drop the frequency it's on and say, oh, wow, you're a top level neuron that's being a little bit louder. I'm going to mimic that frequency.
幸运的是他们很有幽默感。如果你没有幽默感，跟我一起工作会很难。我问杰伊，因为他当时在谈论机器是如何基于大脑会模仿频率的理念工作的。当进行治疗的头盔开始强烈地发出某种频率时，神经元会降低它当前的频率，说：“哦，哇，你是一个声音大一点的高级神经元。我要模仿那个频率。”
I'm going to do what you are doing. That's how it works. You know, basically it's a lot more complicated than that. But that's the grossest reduction of how, you know, neuromodulation works. And I ask Jay, because he's super smart, this dual pH. and then Deanna's got a PhD in electrical engineering. And Jay's a clinical psychologist and experimental research design. I don't forget the other one was in.
“我要做你正在做的事情。”这就是它的工作原理。你知道，基本上比这复杂得多。但这只是神经调节工作原理的最粗略简化。我问杰伊，因为他非常聪明，拥有双博士学位。然后迪安娜拥有电气工程博士学位。杰伊是临床心理学家，擅长实验研究设计。我不记得另一个学位是什么了。
But it's just, you know, infinitely curious people that I like being around and that kind of person. And I was like, look, if you could keep brains alive, right? If they mimic frequency like that, you know, you're the neuroscience. It's not me. Like, if we duct tape them together, would they start to sync up and kind of see, you know, drop redundant structures and make new networks? and Jay was like, oh my gosh, wow, what if I, yeah, oh, wow, yeah, they would. And like, he had a lot of science that I still don't quite, you know, understand.
但这只是，你知道，我喜欢和那些充满好奇心的人在一起，就是那种人。我当时就说，看，如果你能让大脑保持活跃，对吧？如果它们像那样模仿频率，你知道，你是神经科学家。不是我。就像，如果我们用胶带把它们粘在一起，它们会开始同步，并减少冗余结构，建立新的网络吗？杰伊说，哦天哪，哇，如果我，是的，哦，哇，是的，它们会。而且，他有很多我至今还不太理解的科学知识。
But essentially, you know, they would do that if you could, you know, hypothetically pull five or six people's brains out that are still attached to the person, keep their brain alive, keep the person alive, duct tape their brains together where they connected, they would start to function similarly. You would influence each other. And I think that, you know, that Internet and the hypernetwork reality that we were in. And the infinite amount of context points, you know, reflecting that we have to swim through is doing something similar to that to us now, you know.
但本质上，你知道，如果你能假设性地把五六个人的大脑取出来，它们仍然连接在人身上，保持大脑活跃，保持人活着，用胶带把它们的大脑粘在一起，它们就会开始以类似的方式运作。你们会互相影响。我认为，你知道，我们所处的互联网和超网络现实。以及我们必须游过的无限数量的反射性上下文点，现在正在对我们做类似的事情，你知道。
That's a good metaphor for where we are. And, you know, the individual's minds, if you did that, it wouldn't disappear. Everybody would still be, you know, five people, four people, how many brains you want to tuck tape together. But they would gravitate, you know, towards specialized roles within unified, within, you know, a unified whole. Like they would start to prioritize information differently so that the creature that you had made was not being as redundant. People would immediately serve more specialized functions. We think. I mean, this is not been tested, obviously, outside of some kind of J. Horror RPG, some kind of Japanese like, you know, Silent Hill or Hideo Kojima or something.
这是一个很好的比喻，说明我们所处的位置。而且，你知道，如果这样做，个人的思想并不会消失。每个人仍然是，你知道，五个人，四个人，无论你想用胶带粘多少个大脑。但它们会向统一整体内的专门角色靠拢。就像它们会开始以不同的方式优先处理信息，这样你创造出来的生物就不会那么冗余。人们会立即承担更专门的功能。我们认为。我的意思是，这显然没有在某种恐怖角色扮演游戏之外进行过测试，比如某种日本的《寂静岭》或小岛秀夫之类的东西。
You know, so they would develop this new kind of individuality where they're not separate, but they were interdependent and they were offloading information to each other. So each brain became a node in something large, would become, you know, a node in something larger than itself. So this is science fiction, obviously, you know, for now, we're working on something that I hope to reveal next week, but I'm just kidding. You know, we can't actually wire brains together, but we've sort of done that anyway. We've just used a different kind of wire. And so the accelerating speed of digital communication is entwining us into this vastly complex interdependent neural network. Every time you scroll, every time you post, every time you react to something online, every time you like and share this podcast with everyone in your family to make them wonder
你知道，所以它们会发展出一种新的个性，它们不再是独立的，而是相互依存的，它们在互相卸载信息。所以每个大脑都成为了一个更大的东西中的节点。这显然是科幻小说，你知道，目前为止，我们正在研究一些我希望下周能揭晓的东西，但我只是开个玩笑。你知道，我们实际上无法把大脑连接在一起，但我们无论如何都已经这样做了。我们只是用了另一种线。因此，数字通信的加速速度正在将我们缠绕进这个极其复杂、相互依存的神经网络中。每次你滚动屏幕，每次你发帖，每次你在网上对某事做出反应，每次你点赞并把这个播客分享给你的所有家人，让他们怀疑
where you're getting therapy. I'm just kidding. You know, your patterns are being recognized and your frequencies are being incorporated and you're being woven together into something larger. You're offloading a certain amount of critical thinking and you're sort of picking up assumptions from something else that just become part of your wiring, same as a computer. And, you know, we're fusing into this scene. larger being.
你在哪里接受治疗。我只是开个玩笑。你知道，你的模式正在被识别，你的频率正在被整合，你正在被编织进一个更大的东西里。你正在卸载一定量的批判性思维，你正在从别处吸收假设，这些假设变成了你神经连接的一部分，就像计算机一样。而且，你知道，我们正在融合成这个更大的存在。
And just a single brain can develop neuroses in this massive collection, you know, the social brain is experiencing a profound cognitive dissonance. I think the culture being hyperwired together has to be diagnosed on mass as it's sort of a giant brain. So let's dig into it. And let's see in the DSM-5 TR what we would diagnose this giant collective mass of humanity with. Not exactly, but I mean, that's the feeling. That's the anxiety, the polarization, the sense that reality itself has become unstable, and then individuals are going crazy or something.
就像单个大脑会在这个巨大的集合体中产生神经症一样，你知道，社会大脑正在经历深刻的认知失调。我认为这个被高度连接的文化必须被大规模诊断，因为它就像一个巨大的大脑。所以让我们深入研究一下。让我们看看在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》第五版修订版（DSM-5-TR）中，我们会如何诊断这个巨大的人类集体。不完全是这样，但我的意思是，这就是那种感觉。这就是焦虑、两极分化，那种现实本身变得不稳定，然后个人变得疯狂之类的感觉。
I think that is a more common perception than it was, you know, at the beginning of my life when I was, you know, 10 or 20, not as many people were like, everybody's stupid, everybody's going crazy. You know, what's the world coming to? I mean, old people kind of always said that, but it was about much simpler things, like that they didn't teach cursive in school or something. not the sort of things that you see today. And it's that, you know, collective organism that we're becoming. It's going through this developmental crisis. That's what I'm trying to analyze.
我认为这比我生命初期时更常见，你知道，当我10岁或20岁时，没有那么多人说“每个人都很蠢，每个人都疯了”。你知道，“世界怎么了？”我的意思是，老年人总是这么说，但那是因为一些更简单的事情，比如学校不教连体字之类的。而不是你今天看到的那些事情。这就是我们正在变成的那个集体有机体。它正在经历这种发展危机。这就是我试图分析的。
You know, to understand what's happening to our communication, we need to take a step back and look at how human language has worked historically. You know, the media theorist Walter Ong, you've ever read him? He spent his career studying the difference between oral cultures and literate culture. And, you know, this may sound like this academic. distinction, but it's actually a pretty profound difference. You know, in oral cultures, think of Homer's Odyssey or a bard, you know, singing at campfires or elders passing down tribal knowledge through stories.
你知道，要理解我们的交流发生了什么，我们需要退后一步，看看人类语言在历史上是如何运作的。你知道，媒体理论家沃尔特·翁，你读过他的书吗？他毕生致力于研究口头文化和书面文化之间的区别。而且，你知道，这听起来可能是一个学术上的区别，但实际上是一个非常深刻的区别。你知道，在口头文化中，想想荷马的《奥德赛》或者吟游诗人，你知道，在篝火旁唱歌，或者长辈通过故事传授部落知识。
Language worked in a particular way. It was participatory. It was performative. It was mythic. You know, there are the amount of books in the Odyssey is the same that there was in the Greek alphabet at that time, so that you could just sort of yell out the letter of the book of the Odyssey that you wanted the person to read. But there wasn't a permanent record.
语言以一种特定的方式运作。它是参与性的。它是表演性的。它是神话般的。你知道，《奥德赛》中的书卷数量与当时希腊字母表中的字母数量相同，这样你就可以直接喊出你想让人阅读的《奥德赛》书卷的字母。但没有永久的记录。
You know, the stories existed only in the telling. The Odyssey probably changed a lot. We have some evidence that it changed a lot. The Bible changed a lot until it got canonized in the council. And I see a lot of these things were passed down early because that's what information was. We didn't have the idea of static information. Of course it would have to grow and change with the culture. So meaning wasn't fixed.
你知道，故事只存在于讲述之中。《奥德赛》可能改变了很多。我们有一些证据表明它改变了很多。圣经在被委员会定为正典之前也改变了很多。我看到很多这些东西在早期被传下来，因为这就是信息。我们没有静态信息的概念。当然，它必须随着文化的发展而成长和改变。所以意义不是固定的。
Or not exactly. It was flexible. It was forged in this communal space between storyteller and audience, and the story changed depending on who was listening. And what the occasion demanded sometimes, and what felt true in that moment, or needed, true to the audience, not true to the teller. You know, oral cultures thought differently because of this.
或者不完全是。它是灵活的。它是在讲故事的人和听众之间的公共空间中锻造出来的，故事会根据听众的不同而改变。有时根据场合的需求，以及那一刻感觉真实的东西，或者对听众来说是真实的，而不是对讲述者来说是真实的。你知道，口头文化因为这个原因思考方式不同。
Memory worked different. Knowledge worked different. Truth itself worked differently. It wasn't about correspondence with some external reference, record, it was about resonance with lived experience. And then came writing and eventually printing and everything changed. Print culture prioritized permanence. You could write something down, walk away, and would say the same thing a hundred years later.
记忆运作方式不同。知识运作方式不同。真理本身运作方式不同。它不是关于与某种外部参考、记录的对应，而是关于与生活体验的共鸣。然后是书写，最终是印刷，一切都变了。印刷文化优先考虑永久性。你可以写下一些东西，走开，一百年后它说的还是同样的话。
And this shifted us more towards a literalism, an idea that we could accumulate, you know, not immediately, but this building towards this idea that we could accumulate scientific fact, an objective mapping of the world that would just sort of fill up. We used to not know what the map looked like. I'm on this island. Now it's Europe. Now there's this other thing. Oh, now it's connected to that.
这使我们更多地转向了字面主义，一种我们可以积累的想法，你知道，不是立即，而是建立在这个想法之上，即我们可以积累科学事实，一种对世界的客观映射，它会以某种方式填满。我们过去不知道地图是什么样子的。我在这个岛上。现在是欧洲。现在有这个其他东西。哦，现在它连接到那个了。
Now the known world of land ends. Whoa, somebody's selling on a ship. Here's a gap in the ocean. Oh, the map's. Blank edges of the map are filled in. We thought that that same thing would happen with knowledge until we, I don't know, basically knew everything. That's what the idea of literal representation. describes or points you on a path towards in a way that oral representation of language doesn't.
现在已知陆地世界的尽头了。哇，有人在船上航行。这是海洋中的一个缺口。哦，地图的空白边缘被填满了。我们认为同样的事情也会发生在知识上，直到我们，我不知道，基本上知道了所有事情。这就是字面表征的概念所描述或指向的路径，而口头语言表征则不然。
You know, the invention of printing, the printing press. It didn't just give us books. It gave us modern science. You're printing the same thing over and over and over because it doesn't ever need to change. Unless you have a new addition and then you sell it for $500 more, call it the DSM5TR. I'm kidding. Well, I'm not. But, you know, modern law, modern bureaucracy, it gave us this idea.
你知道，印刷术的发明，印刷机。它不仅给了我们书籍。它给了我们现代科学。你一遍又一遍地印刷同样的东西，因为它永远不需要改变。除非你有新版本，然后你以高出500美元的价格卖掉它，称之为DSM-5-TR。我开玩笑的。好吧，我没开玩笑。但是，你知道，现代法律，现代官僚机构，它给了我们这个想法。
That there's one correct interpretation of a text. And that disputes can be resolved by pointing to what the document actually says. That there's sort of a canonical version out there. Unless the author wants you to debate or disagree. And then the point of the text is that. And then I guess that's the canon. Now, this is the world where most of us were trained to navigate that we were born into. We weren't yelling out a Greek letter for Homer to read,
即对文本有一种正确的解释。并且可以通过指出文件实际所说的内容来解决争议。即存在某种正典版本。除非作者想让你辩论或不同意。那么文本的意义就是那样。然后我想那就是正典。现在，这是我们大多数人被训练去导航的世界，我们出生在其中。我们不会为了让吟游诗人阅读《奥德赛》的那一卷而大喊希腊字母，
for the bard to read that book of the Odyssey. we would just look it up and it would always be the same. You know, the world of citations and fact checks, but actually the dictionary defines it as, the world where language is supposed to be precise, where words have specific meanings, where communication is about transmitting information accurately from one mind to another,
我们只会查阅它，它总是相同的。你知道，引文和事实核查的世界，但实际上字典是这样定义的，语言应该是精确的世界，词语有特定含义的世界，交流是关于将信息准确地从一个头脑传送到另一个头脑的世界，
you know, that was this new thing. And so the reason I think Walter Ong is interesting. And I say, if I can't exploit a philosopher in a paragraph, I'm not going to bring them up on here. I'm not going to expect you to bring anything to it. But if you ever want more information about any of these guys, a lot of it is on our blog and they're relevance to what I think, you know, trauma psychology, especially depth psychology.
你知道，那是这件新事物。所以我认为沃尔特·翁很有趣的原因。我说，如果我不能在一段话中利用一位哲学家，我就不会在这里提起他们。我不会指望你从中得到什么。但如果你曾经想了解更多关于这些人的信息，很多都在我们的博客上，以及他们与我认为的，你知道，创伤心理学，特别是深度心理学的相关性。
If you ever curious, you know, I don't expect you to have read them. I usually talk about somebody that I just read. You know, so Walter Ong said that there's electronic media that would thrust us into an era of secondary morality where we would gain the tools of literacy, the permanent archives and searchable databases and the ability to, you know, cite and quote and fact check. You know, but we would use them more in the rhythms of an oral culture. It would be participatory and performative and improvisational.
如果你好奇的话，你知道，我不指望你读过他们。我通常谈论我刚读过的人。你知道，所以沃尔特·翁说，电子媒体会将我们推入一个次要道德时代，在那里我们将获得识字工具、永久档案和可搜索数据库，以及引用、摘录和事实核查的能力。你知道，但我们会更多地在口头文化的节奏中使用它们。它将是参与性的、表演性的和即兴的。
It would return to mythology, but not in our literal belief in mythology. It would return more to a personal expression of the self and the function of religion, essentially, through literal texts, not in place of them. And, you know, that's what is sort of happening. You know, the internet is this library, and it's also a campfire. Every conversation is simultaneously archived forever and created in the moment, and we're operating in both nodes at the same time. And this is unprecedented in human history. You know, we've had people speak different languages with different words before, but we've never spoken different languages with the same words.
它会回归神话，但不是我们对神话的字面信仰。它会更多地回归到自我的个人表达和宗教的功能，本质上，通过字面文本，而不是取代它们。而且，你知道，这就是正在发生的事情。你知道，互联网是这个图书馆，它也是一个篝火。每一次对话都同时被永久存档并在当下创造，我们同时在两个节点上运作。这在人类历史上是前所未有的。你知道，我们以前有过人们用不同的词汇说不同的语言，但我们从未用相同的词汇说过不同的语言。
That's something that is a new phenomenon. The internet is this ultimate artifact of this fusion. Or it's the most visible metaphor, I guess. You know, look at any successful meme. It operates on two frequencies at once, sometimes many more. Now, the image is usually kind of mythic or is archetypal. The distracted boyfriend looking at the red or the blue dress girl. You know, the woman yelling at the confused.
那是一个新现象。互联网是这种融合的终极人工制品。或者它是最明显的隐喻，我想。你知道，看看任何成功的模因。它同时在两个频率上运作，有时更多。现在，图像通常是神话般的或原型的。那个看着红衣或蓝衣女孩的分心男友。你知道，那个对着桌子上困惑的猫大喊的女人。那个坐在燃烧的房间里说“这很好”的狗。它们不仅仅是你分享的某种说“我很高兴，我很伤心”的图片。它们承载着超越任何特定语境的情感共鸣。它们通常描述一种相当复杂的关系，有几个映射到你分享模因的原因、你用模因回应的情况的上下文点。所以文本，与此同时，是高度字面的。
cat at the table. The dog, you know, sitting in a burning room saying, this is fine. They're not really just kind of a picture that you would share that says, like, I'm happy, I'm sad. They carry this emotional resonance that transcends any particular context. They usually describe a fairly complex relationship with several context points that map on to the reason you're sharing the meme, the situation that you're responding to with a meme. And so the text, meanwhile, it's hyper literal.
它是对今天通货膨胀率的具体抱怨。它是对立法片段的精确批评。而且，你知道，它是对昨天发生的事情的引用，明天就会被遗忘。但模因通过融合这两个寄存器来工作。你知道，每个版本都是基于它做得有多好而成功的。它获取你即时的具体焦虑，并将其与永恒的人类模式联系起来。它让你特定的痛苦感觉像是某种内在的东西的一部分。
It's a specific complaint about today's inflation rate. It's a precise critique of pieces of legislation. And, you know, it's reference to something that happened yesterday that will be forgotten tomorrow. But the meme works by fusing these two registers. You know, each aversion is successful based on how well it does that. It takes your immediate specific anxiety and it links it to a timeless human pattern. And it makes your particular suffering feel like part of something internal. E-Term.
抱歉。我没做我的……所以它做了神话一直做的事情。它提供了一个理解经验的框架，但它用这种材料绘制，你知道，来自24小时新闻周期，模因就是这样传播的。这就是为什么分享它们感觉如此令人满意。它们不仅仅是笑话。它们是微小的神话制造行为，将你的上下文映射到巨大的，你知道，他人的上下文或，你知道，原型上下文的故事中。它们是数字时代的篝火故事。
Sorry. I didn't make my E-E-E-E. So it does what. myths have always done. It provides a framework for making sense of experience, but it does it with this material draw, you know, from the 24-hour news cycle, where the memes spread this way. And this is why they feel so satisfying to share. They're not just jokes. They're tiny acts of myth-making, of mapping your context onto a giant, you know, story of others' contexts or, you know, archetypal context. And there are campfire stories of the digital age.
而且很多时候，同时也是字面的论战。但问题就在这里。我的意思是，以前发生过类似的事情。比如，是什么？很多人认为《君主论》之所以被写出来，是因为它有一种双重意图，给皇室、富裕家庭提供实际的坏建议。其他人认为它有点像是在取笑他们，像某种他们会认真对待的东西，比如亿万富翁阶层或等同于亿万富翁阶层的人会认真对待。但其他人会说，哦，他们真的做了。然后你还有像尼禄统治时期的事情。佩特罗尼乌斯，你知道，人们认为《萨蒂利孔》，这部极其淫秽、非常低俗、充满放荡的戏剧，是佩特罗尼乌斯写出来为了取悦尼禄的。
And a lot of times, literal polemic arguments at the same time. But here's the problem. I mean, there are things like this that have happened before. Like, what is it? A lot of people think that the reason the prince was written was it was like a dual intention to give the actual bad advice to the royal family, the rich family. Other people think that it was like sort of to make fun of them, like something that they would take seriously, like a billionaire class or the equivalent
但尼禄会喜欢它，因为它很恶心。但其他人也会看到它并说，哦，你在取笑他有多恶心，因为这太恶心了。这就像，你知道，昆汀·塔伦蒂诺、科恩兄弟版本的宫廷。然后，你知道，有些人对珀耳修斯谈论罗马诗人时也这么说。他的爱情挽歌被认为是有点淫秽以反抗奥古斯都，但同时谈论爱是奴役和奉献，以取笑奥古斯都如何拥有所有这些控制权。所以奥古斯都，你知道，我不认为那个理论站得住脚。但无论如何，回到正题。你知道，文化不会一夜之间进化。
of a billionaire class would take seriously. But everybody else would be like, Oh, they actually did it. And then you also have things like in the reign of Nero. Petronius, you know, people think the satiricon, which is this play that's incredibly lewd, very blue, all this debauchery is happening, was something that Petronius wrote to sort of like please Nero. But Nero would like it because he was gross.
当然有以前发生过这种情况的例子。但根本没有。我的意思是，达到我们在互联网上拥有的速记程度，几乎每个人每天都在多次使用它。所以当每个人同时说两种语言时，而且这些也只是两种含义。许多模因有多种扩展隐喻类型的含义，对吧？你知道，所以现在坏行为者更容易殖民网络的弱节点。这是一个巨魔的天堂。如果你攻击某人的字面论点，他们可以只说，哦，我只是在开玩笑。好吧，真的，眨眨眼，捅捅，其他人，就像，我不是在开玩笑。我是认真的。他们可以退回到符号寄存器中。但如果你攻击他们的，你知道，有毒的象征主义，那么他们可以假装你只是
But also everyone else would see it and be like, oh, you're making fun of how gross he is because this is like so gross. This is like, you know, Quinn Tarantino, the Coen brothers version of the court. And then, you know, some people say the same thing about perpurchus when we're talking about Roman poets. His love elegies are being like kind of lewd to defy Augustus, but at the same time talk about like love is slavery and devotion to like make fun of how Augustine has all this control. And so Augustus is, you know, I don't think that theory holds up as well. But anyway, back to the thing. You know, culture doesn't evolve overnight.
到处看到模式，你疯了。你在互联网的万花筒中进行随机连接。你知道，他们可以要求你用数据证明它。告诉我。嗯，我不知道。我只是很确定。这就是你的意思，伙计。我正在看你的Facebook页面。
Of course there are examples of this happening before. But not at all. I mean, to the extent of the shorthand we have on the Internet now, where it's almost something that everyone is speaking multiple times per day. And so when everyone's speaking two languages at once, and also those are just sort of two meetings. Many memes have like multiple extended metaphor type meetings, right? You know, so it's easier now for bad faith actors
你知道，如果总是有一个内置在一切事物中的逃生舱。所以能够证明某事物的想法，我想很多人意识到，哦，伙计，辩论俱乐部真的不起作用。我们需要做的是意识到，嘿，这是不言而喻的。这有点像成年人知道你的意思。这有点像我们认为不言而喻是真实的事情。所以我们正在远离那种90年代《白宫风云》式的辩论交易。
to easily colonize weak nodes of the network. And this is a troll's paradise. If you attack someone's literal argument, They can just say, oh, I'm just joking. Well, really wink, wink, nudge, nudge, and everyone else, like, I'm not joking. I mean it. And they can retreat into the symbolic register. But if you attack their, you know, toxic symbolism, then they can pretend that you're just
我认为仅仅是出于必要，我们耗尽了它。你知道，有一位我喜欢的媒体学者惠特尼·菲利普斯，她谈到了波定律，或者这个互联网格言，即不可能区分极端观点，你知道，那些是模仿，以及那些观点的模仿，互联网似乎说，我想有点像《萨蒂利孔》。你知道，我们要把这个做成我，你知道，你的百倍亿倍大的版本。我要做这种夸张，或者遵循你所有的信仰到它们的最终结论。好吧，如果你这样做，你是因为你在取笑我还是因为你喜欢我，对吧？而且我的意思是，诚然，我在节目中收到的一些电子邮件，你知道，我没有幻想。
seeing patterns everywhere and that you're crazy. You're making random connection in the kaleidoscope of the internet. You know, they can demand that you prove it with data. Tell me. Well, I don't know. I'm just pretty sure. That's what you mean, man. I'm looking at your Facebook page.
大多数人不喜欢它。但我认为有时我无法分辨，你知道。所以如果你真的无法分辨某人是认真的还是讽刺的，字面的还是象征的，真诚的还是在钓鱼，也许他们自己也无法分辨。而且这不是，这种模糊性不是一个错误。你知道，对某些人来说，这是一个功能。他们可以假装他们相信一切，然后根据发生的事情，他们可以选择更可取的那个。
You know, if there's always this a scale. escape hatch built into everything. And so the idea of being able to prove something, I think a lot of people are realizing, oh, man, debate club doesn't really work. What we need to do is just sort of realize like, hey, this is self-evident. This is kind of what adults know that you mean. This is kind of things that we think are self-evidently true. So we're moving away from that sort of like 90s West Wing, you know, debate type deal.
他们可以假装那是他们一直想的。所以，你知道，想想过去十年的政治悖论。比如当唐纳德·特朗普在2016年当选时，你知道，政治右翼意识到了一种社会意义的真空，叙事。他们把对这种现代英雄神话的需求投射到了这个家伙身上。而且是的，克林顿那边也发生了一些事情。只是，我想，那不是那么流行的神话。
Just by necessity, I think we exhausted it. You know, there's a media scholar I like Whitney Phillips, and she talks about Poe's law, or this internet adage that it's impossible to distinguish from, between extreme views, you know, that are parody and parodies of those views that the internet sort of said, I guess kind of like the satiricon. You know, we're going to make this like a hundred times billion bigger version of what I'm, what I, you know, of you. I'm going to make this exaggeration or follow all of your beliefs to their ultimate penultimate conclusion. Well, if you do that, are you doing it because you're making fun of me or because you like me, right? And I mean, granted, some of the emails I got on the show, you know, I have no illusions.
除了你投射到他们身上的东西之外，那些候选人真的没有太多东西。我认为这让很多没有做太多投射的人感到不安。所以，你知道，这些被提升的80年代和90年代的角色被提升为，你知道，皇帝或，你知道，明智的圣人或他们可能不配得到的投射。而政治，你知道，自由派，你知道，试图通过使用，你知道，后现代字面主义的工具来反击那种神话投射。他们想部署事实核查员，并让公司告诉你模因中的信息是否准确。就像你可以实时监管互联网一样。你知道，顺便说一句，没成功。那些公司倒闭了。他们指出，
Most of people don't like it. But I think that sometimes I can't tell, you know. And so if you genuinely can't tell if someone is being serious or ironic, literal or symbolic, sincere or trolling, maybe they can't either. And this isn't, this kind of ambiguity is not a bug. You know, for some people, that's a feature. They get to pretend like they believe everything, and then depending on what happens, they get to pick the one that is preferable.
你知道，特朗普的财富不是死的，所以他不是真的富有之类的。但我的意思是，见鬼，这家伙一生大部分时间都坐在金王座上。他看起来对我来说很富有，你知道。所以作为一个项目，这失败了。所有这些拆解特朗普的方法。你真的不能用事实核查来击败神话。那不是神话扮演的角色。所以美国选民一再拒绝，你知道，现代自由主义的贫瘠程序化语言，因为它缺乏任何引人注目的未来神话愿景。
They get to pretend that that's what they always thought. So, you know, think about the political paradox of the last decade. Like when Donald Trump got elected in 2016, you know, the political right recognized a societal void of meaning, the narrative. And they projected their need for this modernist heroic myth onto this guy. And yeah, there was some going on with Clinton, too. It just, I guess, wasn't as popular of the myth.
你知道，民主党人把电子表格带到了神话般的战斗中。如果你查看网站的第14页，你知道，你实际上会看到她对那个有什么想法。那根本没用。他们用这种字面寄存器说话，而他们的对手，你知道，在两者上说话。他们更具模因性，他们赢了。无论如何，无论什么是真的，他们赢了。
There really wasn't much to either of those candidates other what you projected onto them. I think that's what made a lot of people upset the people that weren't doing much projected. And so, you know, there's these elevated 80s and 90s characters that got elevated into, you know, emperors or, you know, wise sages or projections they probably didn't deserve. And the political, you know, the liberals, you know, attempted to counter that mythic projection by using the, you know, tools of postmodern literalism. They wanted to deploy fact checkers and have companies that told you whether or not the information in the meme was accurate. Like you could police the internet in real time. You know, didn't work out by the way. Those companies folded. And they pointed out that, you
而且这不是关于一个政党比另一个政党更聪明，因为它来回波动，而且两个竞选团队都做错了很多事情，现在过道的两边仍然做错，两个政党。而且我指的不是错，就像我不同意它。我不同意其中的大部分。我的意思是错，就像它毫无头绪。它不起作用。
know, Trump's wealth wasn't dead so he wasn't actually rich or something. But I mean, hell, the guy's sitting on a gold throne for most of his life. He looks pretty rich to me, you know. So this failed as a project. All of these ways to sort of take Trump apart. You can't really defeat myth with fact-checking. That's not the role that myth plays. And so the American electorate has repeatedly rejected, you know, the sterile procedural language of modern liberalism because it lacks any compelling mythic vision of the future.
他们不明白现在什么是有效的。这是关于理解我们正在运作的语言地形。你知道，你不能用后现代的字面主义来击败现代的神话。你必须综合两者并创造一个新事物。你必须能够在每个寄存器中完全意识到你在做什么的同时，以神话和字面的方式说话。如果你在治疗中与年轻人一起工作，这是年长的治疗师、中年治疗师需要学习做的事情，因为这是与年轻群体进行治疗的重要部分。这是他们说的语言。这不是我在家里说的语言，
You know, the Democrats brought spreadsheets to a mythological battle. And if you check page, you know, 14 of the website, you'll actually see that she thinks something about that. That just didn't work. And they spoke on this literal register while their opponents, you know, were speaking on both. They were more memetic and they won. Whether or not, whatever was true, they won.
但这是我在治疗中与一些人说的语言。在这一点上，一个理性的人可能会反对。难道不是一直都是这样吗？人类难道不是一直，你知道，融合了事实和神话吗？政治家难道不是一直把政策包裹在爱国符号中吗？你知道，政治难道不是一直是一种宗教吗？我们是一个足球队。宗教领袖难道不是一直，你知道，通过字面规则强制执行神话信仰吗？我的意思是，是的，但这是一个公平的批评。你知道，人性改变了那么多，就像我在治疗中经常说的那样。如果这些问题一直追溯到青铜时代，如果它们在圣经中，不要指望它们在你的一生中得到解决。弄清楚如何在它们存在的同时过上幸福的生活，因为它们已经伴随我们很长时间了。
And this isn't about one party of being smarter than the other because it goes back and forth and there are a lot of things that both campaigns did wrong and both sides of the aisle now still do wrong both parties. And I don't mean wrong like I disagree with it. I don't disagree with most of it. I mean wrong like it's clueless. It doesn't work.
自从语言开始以来，人们就一直两面三刀。改变的是过去和速度的媒介。马歇尔·麦克卢汉会说媒介就是信息。你知道，在过去，神话寄存器和字面寄存器，在某种程度上是分开的，神话属于教会、剧院、节日、篝火和文化，而字面属于法院、实验室、报纸和官僚机构。你知道你处于哪种模式是基于语境，不仅是关于所说的话，还有你在哪里。社会生活的架构使它们在某种程度上保持不同，你可以去一个
They don't understand what's effective right now. And it's about understanding the linguistic terrain we're operating in. You know, you can't defeat the myths of the modern with literalism of the postmodern. You have to synthesize both and make a new thing. And you have to be able to speak mythically and literally at the same time with full awareness of what you're doing in each register. And if you're working with younger people in therapy, this is something that older therapists, middle-aged therapists, need to learn to do because it's a big part of doing therapy with a younger population. It's a language that they speak. It's not really a language I speak at home,
当你需要一个时，另一个用于其他事情。互联网强迫两种模式进入完全相同的文本框。是的，我知道如果我们从未发明互联网，教会可能仍然会开始更多地玩科学政治。而且，你知道，科学可能已经继续进化，直到它在某种程度上成为这种存在主义宗教之类的东西。我也听过那些批评。我不，那不是我真正意思。
but it's a language that I speak in therapy with some people. And at this point, a reasonable person might object. Hasn't it always been like this? Haven't humans always, you know, fused facts and myths together? Haven't politicians always wrapped policy in patriotic symbols? You know, hasn't politics always been a religion? We're a football team. Haven't religious leaders always, you know, enforced mythical belief through literal rules? I mean, yeah, but that's a fair critique. You know, human nature has changed that much, like I say in therapy pretty often. If these problems go all the way back to the Bronze Age, if they're in the Bible, don't count on them getting solved in your life. Figure out how to have a happy life while they exist, because they've been with us for a long time.
你知道，这与你报税的同一个平台是你遇到世界末日模因的地方是不一样的，或者包含同行评审研究的同一个信息流，你知道，有部落战争呐喊并卖给你磨剃须刀片的金字塔。或者同样的280个字符有，你知道，同样的语言，像互联网上的13岁孩子和白宫。或者，你知道，反之亦然。你也看到很多青少年以一种，就像，什么？有很多交叉污染，这在某种程度上使一切都成为不同的文化节点，不同的上下文。
People have been speaking out of both sides of their mouth since language began. What's changed is the medium in the past and the speed. Marshall McLuhan would say that the medium is the message. You know, in the in the past, the method register and the literal register, were somewhat separate, and the mythic belonged to the church and the theater and the festival and the campfire and the culture, and the literal belong to the courthouse, the laboratory, the newspaper, and the bureaucracy. And you knew which mode you were in based on the context, not just of what was being said, but where you were. And the architecture of social life kept them somewhat distinct, and you could sort of go to one
点。但这不仅仅是我们一直所做的更快版本。速度是其中的很大一部分。但架构的速度创造了一些质量上新的东西。当每个拥有智能手机的人都被迫成为文化的策展人，你知道，仅仅是为了参与基本的对话，那是一种造成很多焦虑的心理代价。还有另一个因素，叠加在这一切之上的监控和利润基础设施。你知道，平台不是中立的管道。很多模因是关于那个的。它们在取笑它们必须使用的平台，或者谈论它的局限性，比如监控。它们旨在最大化参与度。而参与度是通过触发强烈情感反应的内容来最大化的，
when you needed one and the other for something else. The internet has forced both modes into the exact same text box. Yeah, and I know that if we never invented the internet, that churches probably still would have started to play politics of science more. And, you know, the science would have maybe continued to evolve until it sort of became this existential religion or something. I've heard those critiques too. I don't, that's not really what I mean.
这意味着算法正在系统地放大最神话、最部落、最情绪化的内容。而在压制衡量、细微差别和仅仅是信息性的内容，这也并非原创或新的，你是吗？我们只是在这一点上同意正在发生这种情况，但没有人知道如何阻止它。融合的大脑不仅仅是在有机地表现。它正在被奖励最不稳定交流形式的激励结构所塑造。我们正在使集体大脑生病。认知失调不是偶然的。
You know, it's not the same thing as the same platform where you file your taxes is where you encounter apocalyptic memes or the same feed that contains peer-reviewed research, you know, having tribal war cries and selling you pyramids to sharpen razor blades. Or the same 280 characters have, you know, the same language as like the 13-year-olds on the Internet and the White House. Or, you know, vice versa. You also see a whole lot of teenagers talking about geopolitics in a way that it's like, what? There's a lot of cross-contamination, and that sort of made everything a different cultural node, a different context.
你知道，这和你在同一个平台上报税，却同时看到末日梗图，或者在同一个信息流里既有同行评审的研究，又有部落式的战争呐喊和兜售金字塔形剃须刀片，这完全不是一回事。或者说，同样的280个字符，既承载着互联网上13岁孩子的语言，也承载着白宫的官方声明，反之亦然。你还会看到很多青少年以一种让人匪夷所思的方式谈论地缘政治。这里存在大量的交叉污染，这使得一切都变成了一个不同的文化节点，一个不同的语境。
point. And this isn't just a faster version of what we've always done, though. The speed is a big part of it. But the speed of the architecture have created something qualitatively new. When everyone with a smartphone is forced to be a curator of cultural, you know, just to participate in a basic conversation, that's a psychological toll that causes a lot of anxiety. And there's another factor, the surveillance and profit infrastructure that's been put on top of all of this. You know, the platforms aren't neutral pipes. A lot of the memes are about that. They're making fun of the platform that they have to use or talking about the limitations of it like surveillance. They're designed to maximize engagement. An engagement is maximized by content that triggers strong emotional responses,
观点。但这不仅仅是我们一直以来所做之事的加速版。速度确实是其中很大的一部分，但这种架构的速度创造了一些质上全新的东西。当每个拥有智能手机的人为了参与基本的对话，被迫成为文化的策展人时，这会带来巨大的心理负担，导致很多焦虑。还有一个因素，就是叠加在这一切之上的监控和盈利基础设施。你知道，这些平台并非中立的管道。很多梗图都是关于这一点的。它们在嘲笑自己不得不使用的平台，或者讨论其局限性，比如监控。它们的设计初衷是最大化参与度，而参与度是通过触发强烈情绪反应的内容来最大化的，
which means the algorithms are systematically amplifying the most mythic, the most tribal, the most emotionally charged content. And while suppressing the measure, the nuanced, and the merely informative, this is also not an original or new, are you? We just sort of at this point agree that that's happening, but nobody knows how to stop it. The fused brain isn't just performing organically. It's being shaped by incentive structures that reward the most destabilizing forms of communication. We are making the collective brain sick. The cognitive dissonance isn't accidental.
这意味着算法正在系统性地放大那些最具神话色彩、最部落化、最情绪化的内容，同时压制那些理性的、细致的、纯粹信息性的内容。这也不是什么原创或新鲜事，对吧？我们现在基本上都同意这种情况正在发生，但没人知道该如何阻止它。这种融合的大脑不仅仅是在有机地运作，它正在被激励结构所塑造，而这些结构奖励的是最具破坏性的沟通方式。我们正在让集体大脑生病。这种认知失调并非偶然。
I think that it's profitable. Panic is profitable. Trauma is profitable. And what I've started to hear in therapy is a lot of people saying, Yeah, yeah, yeah. I can get rid of my panic. I can get rid of my trauma. I can get rid of my anxiety. But how do I function in the world?
我认为这是有利可图的。恐慌是有利可图的。创伤是有利可图的。我在治疗中开始听到很多人说：“是的，是的，是的。我可以摆脱恐慌，我可以摆脱创伤，我可以摆脱焦虑。但我该如何在这个世界上生存呢？”
Because you sort of have to have that in order to be connected now. I don't have a fast answer to that question. It's what leads me to make podcasts like this. You know, here's something that we need to confront honestly. The viral political moments often fail. Not just fall short of their goals. They fail completely at the material level, while appearing to succeed everywhere else.
因为你现在必须拥有这些才能与世界保持联系。对于这个问题，我没有快速的答案。这正是促使我制作这类播客的原因。你知道，这是我们需要诚实面对的事情。病毒式的政治时刻往往会失败。不仅仅是达不到目标，它们在物质层面上彻底失败了，尽管它们在其他方面看起来都很成功。
Think about Occupy Wall Street. On a symbolic and mythic level, it was an extraordinary success. It changed the vocabulary of American politics, and the 99% entered the language. Income inequality became mainstream talking point. The images spread everywhere, and the memes propagated wildly. And Occupy dominated the symbolic landscape. But on a literal and a procedural level,
想想“占领华尔街”。在象征和神话层面上，它取得了非凡的成功。它改变了美国政治的词汇，“99%”进入了语言体系。收入不平等成为了主流话题。图像到处传播，模因疯狂扩散。占领运动主导了象征性的景观。但在字面和程序层面上，
the level where, you know, actual laws get ridden, and institutional power gets wielded, it was a complete material failure. No lasting policy change sustained. No organizational structures endured. No actual power and specifically money changed hands. And the banks that crashed the economy in 2008 are bigger now than they ever were. A lot of them took, well, one of them took the money that was used for the bailout, said we're closing the bank, paid it to themselves as bonus.
也就是制定实际法律、行使制度权力的层面，它在物质上是彻底的失败。没有任何持久的政策变革得以维持。没有任何组织结构得以延续。没有任何实际权力，特别是金钱，发生转移。而在2008年导致经济崩溃的银行，现在比以往任何时候都更大。它们中的许多，好吧，其中一家拿了用于救助的钱，说我们要关闭银行，然后把钱作为奖金发给了自己。
and that was perfectly legal. Occupy Wall Street failed. There's sort of a similar trajectory with other giant mainstream cultural movement. And cancel culture, Black Lives Matter, where they attained an enormous amount of cultural control but didn't really affect any real change. The literal level of material change,
而这完全是合法的。“占领华尔街”失败了。其他大型主流文化运动也有类似的轨迹。比如“取消文化”、“黑人的命也是命”，它们获得了巨大的文化控制权，但并没有真正带来任何实质性的改变。在物质变革的字面层面上，
not the oral culture of the myth? Police budgets weren't cut after BLM. They increased. Qualified immunity wasn't ended. The structural reformed that might actually have accomplished some of the goals of the movement didn't happen. You know, these movements illustrate the trap that Adam Curtis was talking about, and I talked about Adam Curtis three episodes ago,
而不是神话的口头文化层面？BLM运动之后，警察预算并没有被削减。反而增加了。有限豁免权没有被终结。那些本可以真正实现运动目标的结构性改革并没有发生。你知道，这些运动说明了亚当·柯蒂斯所谈论的陷阱，我在三集前也谈到过亚当·柯蒂斯，
they're kind of proving his point. That symbolic register of cultural control, you know, oral culture, it doesn't really do anything to affect the literal culture. And it doesn't make, you know, a cultural symbolic oral win doesn't turn into a literal written material culture win. They're two different things, even if they share overlapping symbols. And those movements often mustook the symbols for the same thing. Because they use the same symbol, they must be the same thing.
它们在某种程度上证明了他的观点。那种文化控制的象征性记录，也就是口头文化，对影响字面文化并没有什么实际作用。而且，你知道，一场文化象征性的口头胜利并不会转化为字面书写的物质文化胜利。它们是两回事，即使它们共享重叠的符号。而这些运动往往把符号误认为是同一件事。因为它们使用相同的符号，所以它们一定是同一件事。
The movements failed because they weren't. You know, when you win symbolically, it feels like you won. The brain lights up with recognition and you see your language used everywhere. You see yourself on the news and you feel like that's part of something powerful. But it's not. The sense of momentum is real. but the material conditions haven't changed. And I don't think that our culture, especially people my age, given similar opportunities,
这些运动失败了，因为它们并非如此。你知道，当你在象征意义上获胜时，感觉就像你赢了一样。大脑因认同感而点亮，你看到自己的语言被到处使用。你在新闻中看到自己，感觉自己是某种强大事物的一部分。但事实并非如此。动力的感觉是真实的，但物质条件并没有改变。我不认为我们的文化，尤其是像我这个年纪的人，在获得类似机会的情况下，
are going to make that same mistake again. That trap of digital activism, not even digital activism, because Occupy Wall Street was buried not digital, was on the ground. You know, companies pander to these things all the time, like, you know, BLM or MAGA or any of these movements, and they get symbolic alignment to drive material gain, but it doesn't really change their material practices and the aims of the movement.
会再次犯同样的错误。那种数字激进主义的陷阱，甚至不是数字激进主义，因为“占领华尔街”并不是数字化的，它是实地进行的。你知道，公司总是迎合这些事情，比如BLM或MAGA或任何这些运动，它们获得象征性的结盟来推动物质收益，但这并没有真正改变它们的物质实践和运动的目标。
This confusion between the symbolic and the material victory, it's not just an innocent mistake, or at least not always. There's this powerful interest, I think, actively cultivate some of this stuff. But people are noticing that, and as they're noticing that, they're not as resistant to it anymore. The collective brain is changing.
这种在象征性胜利和物质胜利之间的混淆，不仅仅是一个无心的错误，或者至少不总是这样。我认为，有强大的利益集团在积极培养其中的一些东西。但人们正在注意到这一点，随着他们的注意，他们不再那么容易被其左右了。集体大脑正在发生变化。
And how could it really know how to deal with these new forms of control until it tried the old solution over and over and over again and watched it fail. That's how people in individual therapy realize that there is a problem, that they need a new solution. So I think culture is kind of the same. You know, maybe some of the more savvy people pointed this out for a long time and got angry, but that's not how change works. You know, and that's why I call something like, you know, that viral internet world, the dream time, like the aboriginals talked about, that symbolic layer.
在尝试了旧的解决方案一次又一次并看着它失败之前，它怎么可能真正知道如何处理这些新的控制形式呢？这就是个人治疗中的人们意识到存在问题、需要新解决方案的方式。所以我认为文化也是一样的。你知道，也许一些更精明的人早就指出了这一点并感到愤怒，但变革不是那样运作的。你知道，这就是为什么我把那种病毒式的互联网世界称为“梦幻时代”，就像原住民所谈论的那样，那种象征性的层面。
because it has literal elements, but it also has mythical timeless ones. It's sort of our, not religion, but like our shared mythology, has become more complicated. David Bum's a physicist and a philosopher that is kind of interesting. And, you know, he wrote this book called Thought as a System, where he argues something that sounds kind of obvious, but it has bigger implications he flushes out. That, you know, thought is not something we do. It's something that happens to us. It's a system that operates through us, not the tools we control.
因为它有字面的元素，但也有神话般永恒的元素。它有点像我们的——不是宗教，而是像我们共享的神话，变得更加复杂了。大卫·玻姆是一位物理学家和哲学家，他很有趣。你知道，他写了一本名为《思想作为一种系统》的书，他在书中提出了一个听起来很显而易见，但却有他所阐述的更大含义的观点。那就是，思想不是我们做的事情。它是发生在我们身上的事情。它是一个通过我们运作的系统，而不是我们控制的工具。
We are filtering mechanisms for the world, and our thoughts are us applying our predictive filter. They're not just things that we create. They're things that we filter out of all of the noise of existing. And Bohn was a quantum physicist, and he worked with Einstein, at least until Einstein, you know, until he started doing quantum physics because Einstein was classical and didn't really like that stuff. But, you know, he spent his last years trying to understand why human beings seemed incapable of solving problems that are clearly solvable. Climate change, nuclear weapons, inequality, you know, protecting children from being abused, having, you know, a world that is relatively fair financially. Like these were things that he would thought would be self-evident.
我们是世界的过滤机制，我们的思想是我们应用预测过滤器的过程。它们不仅仅是我们创造的东西。它们是我们从现存的所有噪音中过滤出来的东西。玻姆是一位量子物理学家，他曾与爱因斯坦共事，至少在爱因斯坦开始做量子物理学之前，因为爱因斯坦是古典派，不太喜欢那些东西。但是，你知道，他晚年致力于理解为什么人类似乎无法解决那些显然可以解决的问题。气候变化、核武器、不平等，你知道，保护儿童免受虐待，拥有一个在经济上相对公平的世界。这些是他认为不言自明的事情。
People would say, hey, let's all go ahead and pursue this. Yet in life, he looked around, nobody's really pursuing those. And we could even see the solutions. People could talk about them. But huge groups of people couldn't sit down and do them. Why? His answer was that thought itself was the problem. Not wrong thoughts that need to be replaced with right thoughts, the structure of thought,
人们会说，嘿，让我们一起去追求这个吧。然而在生活中，他环顾四周，没有人真正追求这些。我们甚至可以看到解决方案。人们可以谈论它们。但庞大的人群却无法坐下来去执行它们。为什么？他的回答是，思想本身就是问题所在。不是需要被正确思想取代的错误思想，而是思想的结构，
which is a weird idea, but this is what he meant. You know, we assume that our thoughts are our own, that they arise from our individual mind, and they reflect our individual perception and express our individual will. But Bohm argued that the vast majority of what we think is, not individual at all. It's collective. He got to the same place with math that Jung, you know, Carl Jung, had gotten to with phenomenology. Bome said it's inherited. It's the residue of everything that our culture has thought before us running automatically through our nervous system. And we need to be
这是一个奇怪的想法，但这正是他的意思。你知道，我们假设我们的思想是我们自己的，它们源于我们个人的头脑，反映了我们的个人感知并表达了我们的个人意志。但玻姆认为，我们所想的绝大多数内容根本不是个人的。它是集体的。他在数学上得出的结论与荣格（卡尔·荣格）在现象学上得出的结论是一样的。玻姆说它是遗传的。它是我们文化在我们之前所想的一切的残留物，自动地流经我们的神经系统。我们需要
aware of those old thoughts. Thought he said had become systematic. It operated like an immune system, automatically defending itself against anything that threatened its coherence. When you encounter information that contradicts your worldview, thought doesn't calmly evaluate the evidence. It reacts. It defends it attacks. It does this faster than you yourself can consciously intervene because conscious intervention is itself just more thought operating within the same system. And this means that collective thought, the shared assumptions, narratives, and frameworks of a culture, the dream time, as I would call it, that increasingly controls individual thought without anyone noticing. You think you're thinking your own thoughts. You're actually running inherited
意识到那些旧的思想。他说，思想已经变得系统化了。它像免疫系统一样运作，自动防御任何威胁其连贯性的事物。当你遇到与你的世界观相矛盾的信息时，思想不会冷静地评估证据。它会做出反应。它会防御，它会攻击。它这样做比你本人能够有意识地干预的速度还要快，因为有意识的干预本身只是在同一个系统内运作的更多思想。这意味着集体思想，即文化的共享假设、叙事和框架——也就是我所说的“梦幻时代”——在无人察觉的情况下越来越多地控制着个人思想。你以为你在思考自己的思想，实际上你是在运行遗传的
programs. The system is thinking itself through you. But humans, you know, are bad giving up individual agency. We don't want to see it that way. And he said this in 94, you know, before social media, before smartphones, before algorithms, before amplification of everything. Now imagine what Bohm would say if he was to look at meme culture now. about a world where collective thought forms propagate at the speed of light, where the most viral ideas are the ones that trigger the strongest automatic reaction, and where the algorithm's infrastructure is specifically designed to hijack the immune system, or that immune response, the quality of thought, to make ideas spread,
程序。系统正在通过你思考它自己。但人类，你知道，不擅长放弃个人代理权。我们不想那样看。他在94年就说了这一点，你知道，在社交媒体、智能手机、算法、一切事物被放大之前。现在想象一下，如果玻姆看到现在的模因文化会怎么说。关于一个集体思想形式以光速传播的世界，最病毒式的想法是那些触发最强烈自动反应的想法，而算法的基础设施是专门为了劫持免疫系统，或者那种免疫反应、思想质量而设计的，为了让想法传播，
not because they're true, but because they are triggering. This system's been turbocharged. The collection, you know, that collectivized, thinking that Bohm warned about has been given technological steroids, and the loss of individual authenticity he described has accelerated to the point where many people don't even have a concept of what individual thought would feel like. They've never experienced it. The collective has colonized them completely, but they're still ready to, you know, fight hard to defend this thing that feels like them. The guide aboard is another one that I've talked about before. In 1967, you know,
不是因为它们是真的，而是因为它们具有触发性。这个系统已经被涡轮增压了。玻姆所警告的那种集体化思维被注入了技术类固醇，他所描述的个人真实性的丧失已经加速到许多人甚至没有“个人思想会是什么感觉”的概念。他们从未体验过。集体已经完全殖民了他们，但他们仍然准备好，你知道，拼命捍卫这个感觉像是他们自己的东西。居伊·德波是我之前谈到过的另一个人。1967年，你知道，
he wrote the Society of Spectacle, a book that reads like prophecy now, but it was considered this obscure theory at the time. DeBoard argued that modern capitalism had transformed social life into an accumulation of spectacles, representations that replace direct experience with mediated images. All that once was directly lived has become mere representation. He says,
他写了《景观社会》，这本书现在读起来像预言，但在当时被认为是一种晦涩的理论。德波认为，现代资本主义已经将社会生活转化为景观的积累，即用中介图像取代直接体验的表象。所有曾经直接生活的东西都变成了纯粹的表象。他说，
life under the spectacle isn't lived, it's watched, it's consumed, it's experienced, at a remove through screens and images and narratives that stand between you and reality. The spectacle isn't just entertainment or distraction. It includes those things, but it's a social relationship between people mediated by images. And it's what happens when the representation becomes more real than the thing represented, when the map doesn't just obscure the territory, but it replaces it entirely,
景观下的生活不是被生活的，而是被观看的、被消费的、被体验的，通过屏幕、图像和叙事在遥远的地方，它们横亘在你和现实之间。景观不仅仅是娱乐或消遣。它包括这些东西，但它是人与人之间通过图像中介的社会关系。当表象变得比被表象的事物更真实时，当地图不仅遮蔽了领土，而且完全取代了它时，就会发生这种情况，
like we talked about in the last episode. Now, DeBoard was writing about television, about advertising, sometimes how you couldn't tell the show from the ad, but about the emerging media environment of the 60s. You know, his analysis applies with pretty good precision to the internet now. But here's where DeBoard connects with Bohm. The spectacle thinks through us. DeBoard understood that the spectacle wasn't just something that we watch.
就像我们在上一集谈到的那样。现在，德波写的是关于电视、广告，有时关于你如何无法区分节目和广告，但关于60年代新兴的媒体环境。你知道，他的分析现在可以相当精确地应用于互联网。但这就是德波与玻姆联系的地方。景观通过我们思考。德波明白，景观不仅仅是我们观看的东西。
It's something that our structures thought. The images and the narratives of the spectacle become the categories we use to understand experience. And we don't just see the spectacle, we see through it. It becomes the lens, not the object. And this is why you can know that social media is manipulating you and still be manipulated. The knowing happens within the spectacle.
它是我们思想的结构。景观的图像和叙事成为了我们用来理解经验的范畴。我们不仅看到景观，我们透过它看。它成为了透镜，而不是对象。这就是为什么你可以知道社交媒体在操纵你，却仍然被操纵。这种“知道”发生在景观之内。
The critique happens within the spectacle. Even your resistance is captured and displayed as another image in an endless flow. And a board called this the colonization of everyday life. The spectacle doesn't stay on the screen. It colonizes your relationships. your desires, your sense of who you are. You start to experience your own life as content
批判发生在景观之内。甚至你的抵抗也被捕获并显示为无尽流动中的另一个图像。德波称之为“日常生活殖民化”。景观不会停留在屏幕上。它殖民了你的人际关系、你的欲望、你对你是谁的感觉。你开始将自己的生活体验为内容，
and think about content as it relates to your life. You start to perform your existence for an imagined audience. You become a character in your own personal spectacle watching yourself from the outside. I was kind of shocked to hear when I was in college that psychologists were starting to see this new delusion where people felt like they were being watched and recorded all the time and they were exhausted from having to stay in character and act and set a good example
并思考与你生活相关的内容。你开始为一个想象中的观众表演你的存在。你成为了你自己个人景观中的一个角色，从外部观察自己。我在大学时听到心理学家开始看到这种新的妄想时感到很震惊，人们觉得他们一直被监视和记录，他们因为必须保持角色、表演并树立好榜样而精疲力竭，
and for all these people watching them, but they were completely alone. You know, this phenomenon had created a new kind of psychosis that had not been seen before. And you know, and the younger and the more online you are, the more you feel this, and it's why people that are younger tend to like these kind of episodes more, and older people tend to say what the hell are you talking about. The more natural it seems to narrate your experience as your, having it if you're younger and to frame moments for their shareability to evaluate your emotions by how you would work an audience and it's because these
为了所有这些看着他们的人，但他们却完全孤独。你知道，这种现象创造了一种以前从未见过的精神病。而且，你知道，你越年轻、越常上网，你就越有这种感觉，这就是为什么年轻人往往更喜欢这类剧集，而老年人往往会说你在胡说什么。如果你更年轻，叙述你的体验就像你在经历它一样，为了可分享性而构建时刻，通过你如何调动观众来评估你的情绪，这显得越自然，这是因为这些
kids started feeling this at four at six two not at 45 and look what it did to the 45-year-old and there's a temptation that comes with the awareness of the network once you feel connected to everything is once you sense the power of viral propagation and you start to look for soft spots you start to see how far your tendrils can get you start to see what new regions of this network that you can hack into and exploit and how much power you have something humans are very good at doing and you start to play the game of influence trying to colonize others before they colonize you and multiple networks push against each other multiple spectacles competing for attention and all
孩子们从四岁、六岁就开始有这种感觉，而不是45岁，看看它对45岁的人做了什么。一旦你感觉到与一切事物的联系，一旦你感觉到病毒式传播的力量，你就会开始寻找软肋，你就会开始看到你的触角能伸多远，你就会开始看到你可以黑入并利用这个网络的哪些新区域，以及你拥有多少权力——这是人类非常擅长做的事情——你就会开始玩影响力的游戏，试图在别人殖民你之前先殖民他们，多个网络相互挤压，多个景观争夺注意力，所有
of them running through the same nervous system the same thought process the same humans who have less and less sense of where the collective ends and they begin. And it's exhilarating and sometimes it's thrilling, but it's exhausting. And it's ultimately hollow if it doesn't connect to actual material change to something that happens in reality rather than in the endless circulation of the image. And here's what I'm trying to say precisely. We are so fused together now that the collective psychology is functioning like an individual psychology. Not matter. Metaphorically, not loose analogy, the same process that happens in an individual mind Pathology defense mechanisms personality disorders grandiosity delusion psychosis
这些都流经同一个神经系统，同一个思维过程，同一个人类，他们越来越不知道集体在哪里结束，他们自己从哪里开始。这令人振奋，有时令人激动，但令人精疲力竭。如果它不能连接到实际的物质变革，连接到发生在现实中而不是图像无尽循环中的事情，它最终是空洞的。这就是我想要精确表达的。我们现在融合得如此紧密，以至于集体心理学的功能就像个人心理学一样。不是比喻，不是松散的类比，而是发生在个人头脑中的相同过程。病理、防御机制、人格障碍、自大、妄想、精神病，
They're happening at the collective level and I'm not saying that this is entirely new people have been making arguments about the collective psychology since the 1970s Youing talked about the collective unconscious Systems theories talk about emergent group behavior and there's a whole transpersonal psychology movement and the new age thing signs different etiottis but the same idea. There's a whole literature on how crowds think differently than individuals and how nations develop something like personality, how culture can become pathological. But here's what's different now. It's happening in real time. The speed of connection has collapsed the timescales and what used to take generations now takes months. What used to take years now takes weeks and the feedback loops are so fast, so tight, so interconnected, that you can watch the collective pathology to develop the way that you'd watch a time lapse of a disease spreading through the body.
它们正在集体层面发生。我并不是说这是全新的，自1970年代以来人们一直在争论集体心理学。荣格谈论集体潜意识，系统理论谈论涌现的群体行为，还有一个完整的超个人心理学运动，新时代的东西标志着不同的病因，但想法是一样的。关于人群如何与个人不同地思考，国家如何发展出类似人格的东西，文化如何变得病态，有大量的文献。但现在不同的是：它正在实时发生。连接的速度压缩了时间尺度，过去需要几代人的时间，现在只需要几个月。过去需要几年的时间，现在只需要几周，反馈回路如此之快、如此紧密、如此相互关联，以至于你可以观察集体病理的发展，就像你观察疾病在体内传播的延时摄影一样。
And I want to be clear about what I'm saying. I'm not saying that the planet, in some vague mystical sense, or Gaia, you know, has a headache. I'm saying that more specific and more disturbing collective groups of humanity can now be analyzed almost the same way that you would analyze a patient in therapy. You can identify the defenses. You can trace the trauma. You can see the splitting, the projection, the denial. You can almost run an MBTI on certain collections.
我想明确我所说的话。我不是说地球在某种模糊的神秘意义上，或者盖亚，你知道，头痛了。我是说，更具体、更令人不安的人类集体群体现在几乎可以用你分析治疗中的病人的方式来分析。你可以识别防御。你可以追踪创伤。你可以看到分裂、投射、否认。你几乎可以在某些集合上运行MBTI。
And you can watch the collective do exactly what an individual does when they're confronted with something that they can't face or that they don't want to when they don't want to change, which for people is most of the time. What you see on the internet now is collectivized brains fighting against other networks of brains and trying to expand. Assessing out weaker regions, finding the nodes that weren't well defended, going in, taking them over.
你可以观察集体在面对他们无法面对或不想面对的事情时，在他们不想改变时——这对人们来说是大多数时候——做出与个人完全一样的事情。你现在在互联网上看到的是集体化的大脑在与其他大脑网络战斗并试图扩张。评估出较弱的区域，找到防御不好的节点，进入，接管它们。
But what are they looking for? Wounds, hurts, grievances, trauma, the fuel that runs the world. More valuable than gold and more valuable than oil. Populations that felt abandoned, humiliated, forgot. They keep that unconscious and want to project it on something else. The colonizers weren't creating pain. They were finding existing pain and exploiting it.
但他们在寻找什么？伤口、痛苦、不满、创伤，驱动世界的燃料。比黄金更有价值，比石油更有价值。感到被遗弃、羞辱、遗忘的人群。他们保持这种潜意识，并想把它投射到其他事物上。殖民者并没有制造痛苦。他们是在寻找现有的痛苦并加以利用。
I know that sounds like imperialism. I know it just sounds like what colonialism and exploitation and neoliberalism have always done. But there are theories about that. Scholars have been documenting how powerful interests find vulnerable populations and exploit them for centuries. And I'm saying there's a new layer now, something that operates on the top of the old colonial dynamics,
我知道这听起来像帝国主义。我知道这听起来就像殖民主义、剥削和新自由主义一直所做的那样。但有关于此的理论。学者们几个世纪以来一直在记录强大的利益集团如何寻找弱势群体并剥削他们。而我说现在有一个新的层面，某种在旧殖民动态之上运作的东西，
but it moves faster and it works differently. In traditional imperialism, colonialism, you needed ships and armies and supply lines and years, decades, propaganda, printing presses. And the digital colonization, the collective brain, this happens at the speed of thought. A wound gets identified, a narrative gets crafted, a meme gets deployed. Before anyone can organize a response, the colonialization is complete, and the population has already internalized this new story. The new oral pathway has already been laid down.
但它移动得更快，运作方式也不同。在传统的帝国主义、殖民主义中，你需要船只、军队、补给线和几年、几十年的宣传、印刷机。而在数字殖民化中，集体大脑，这发生在思想的速度上。一个伤口被识别，一个叙事被精心制作，一个模因被部署。在任何人能够组织回应之前，殖民化已经完成，人口已经内化了这个新故事。新的口头路径已经铺设好了。
And pain, trauma, is the unhealed psychological sublayer. for the road. There's two things that are scary to me about this. One, how do you incentivize a world to heal trauma that profits from it? And then two, what happens when you make this process even faster with AI that doesn't know what it's doing, that is operating inside of a black box,
而痛苦、创伤，是未愈合的心理底层。对于这条路。有两件事让我感到害怕。第一，你如何激励一个从中获利的世界去治愈创伤？然后第二，当你用不知道自己在做什么、在黑匣子内运作的人工智能让这个过程变得更快时，会发生什么？
and it's given control of the data that can identify this information? You know, this is happening constantly. What I'm talking about is just right now, not the future of this thing. Multiple networks competing to colonize the same vulnerable populations. Looking for any wound, any hurt, any grievance that can be leveraged. The collective brain is a battlefield where different factions fight for control of attention. It's a hacking competition.
并且它被赋予了可以识别这些信息的数据的控制权？你知道，这一直在发生。我所谈论的只是现在，而不是这件事的未来。多个网络竞争殖民同一个弱势群体。寻找任何可以利用的伤口、痛苦、不满。集体大脑是一个战场，不同的派系争夺注意力的控制权。这是一场黑客竞赛。
Not a battlefield. That was a bad analogy. It's a hacking competition. It's cyberpunk. And here's where the therapy analogy becomes more literal. If you've ever looked at a patient who's confronting something, they don't want to face an addiction a trauma a pattern of behavior that's destroying their life their chance of survival you know there's a consequence or you know a sequence consequence to you
不是战场。那是个糟糕的类比。这是一场黑客竞赛。这是赛博朋克。这就是治疗类比变得更字面的地方。如果你曾经观察过一个正在面对他们不想面对的事情的病人——成瘾、创伤、正在摧毁他们生活、生存机会的行为模式——你知道有一个后果，或者你知道一个序列后果，
pointing it out or a sequence of working through it you know a predictable set of defenses that the patient moves through first you know it didn't happen okay it happened but it's not real okay it's real but it doesn't matter okay it matters but we can't do anything about it okay maybe something could be done but someone else will do it. For me to do it is unreasonable. Okay, it's not getting solved, but it's someone else's fault. And so I don't have a choice. Someone else did it so they're the real person at fault for the thing that I'm doing
指出它，或者经历它的序列，你知道病人经历的一系列可预测的防御：首先，你知道，它没有发生；好吧，它发生了，但它不是真的；好吧，它是真的，但它不重要；好吧，它很重要，但我们无能为力；好吧，也许可以做点什么，但别人会做。让我去做是不合理的。好吧，它没有被解决，但这是别人的错。所以我没有选择。别人做了，所以他们才是对我正在做的事情负有真正责任的人，
because they made me. Okay, it's going to take us all out, but we deserve it. You know, there's all of these problems that you see in the therapy room that you can work through because they're the path to change. You can't jump straight from that to acceptance. You have to help somebody accept something. But right now, how does this culture help it accept itself or any of its problems on a mass scale? You know, the denial, all of these things are things that we are doing right now.
因为他们逼我。好吧，它会把我们都带走，但我们活该。你知道，你在治疗室里看到的这些问题，你可以通过它们，因为它们是通往改变的道路。你不能直接从那跳到接受。你必须帮助某人接受某事。但现在，这种文化如何帮助它在大规模上接受它自己或它的任何问题？你知道，否认，所有这些事情都是我们现在正在做的事情。
Can a collective do the solution? Can humanity as a whole hit bottom and decide to change? That's the question that we don't know the answer to. We've never been fused together so tightly enough to find that out. And we've never had a collective crisis that moved fast enough to force collective reckoning. And the crisis is starting to move even faster. We now live in parallel objectivities. Different populations inhabit different realities, sometimes in the same country, the same state, the same household.
集体能做到解决方案吗？人类作为一个整体能触底反弹并决定改变吗？这是我们不知道答案的问题。我们从未融合得如此紧密以至于能发现这一点。我们也从未有过移动得足够快以至于迫使集体清算的集体危机。而危机开始移动得更快了。我们现在生活在平行的客观性中。不同的人群居住在不同的现实中，有时在同一个国家、同一个州、同一个家庭。
Not just different opinions about the same facts, but genuine different facts, different evidentiary standards, different criteria for what counts. For some people, literal truth is literal truth. For other people, their mythic world is literal truth, and they don't know what scientific fact is. Some people just make their phenomenological, internal, subjective, and religious experiences. They're literal facts. They operate entirely on intuition, leaving them blind to where their intuition is colored at the source by trauma. And that's something that is increasing its scope in our world. These parallel objective realities are not just tribal disagreements.
不仅仅是对相同事实的不同意见，而是真正不同的事实、不同的证据标准、不同的衡量标准。对一些人来说，字面真理就是字面真理。对另一些人来说，他们的神话世界就是字面真理，他们不知道什么是科学事实。有些人只是把他们的现象学、内在、主观和宗教体验当作字面事实。他们完全凭直觉行事，这使他们对直觉在源头上被创伤着色的地方视而不见。这是在我们世界中范围正在扩大的事情。这些平行的客观现实不仅仅是部落分歧。
They're something stranger. There are systems of representation that have become self-contained. They're coherent internally. They're reproducible. They're reliable in the sense that they generate consistent outputs when they get consistent inputs. But they have all these features that we associate with objectivity. That's why I brought up the cargo cult last time. But they're not valid.
它们是更奇怪的东西。它们是已经变得自给自足的表象系统。它们在内部是连贯的。它们是可复制的。它们是可靠的，在这个意义上，当它们获得一致的输入时，它们会产生一致的输出。但它们具有我们与客观性相关联的所有特征。这就是我上次提到“货物崇拜”的原因。但它们不是有效的。
They don't point back to anything real or anything actually true. So here's a concrete example. You know, I watch patients drop out of treatment, not because they're not better, or therapy's not working. it's because they can't afford $15 or $30 copay. Recently, this has been more of a problem. We've all seen it, and I talked to other therapists. They're choosing between their mental health and groceries, and so they have to choose groceries.
它们并不指向任何真实或真正正确的东西。所以这是一个具体的例子。你知道，我看着病人退出治疗，不是因为他们没有好转，或者治疗没有效果，而是因为他们负担不起15或30美元的共付额。最近，这成了更多的问题。我们都看到了，我和其他治疗师谈过。他们在心理健康和杂货之间做选择，所以他们必须选择杂货。
But the official metrics say that the economy's fine. The GDP's up. Unemployment is down. The stock market has helped. All the objective metrics of this thing say that everyone's doing good, but it doesn't feel that way to me. What does that do to my brain? By every measure that the institutions track, we're in good shape, but my patients can't afford a $30 copay.
但官方指标说经济很好。GDP上升了。失业率下降了。股市有所帮助。这件事的所有客观指标都说每个人都做得很好，但对我来说感觉不是这样。这对我的大脑有什么影响？按照机构追踪的每一项衡量标准，我们状况良好，但我的病人负担不起30美元的共付额。
And those metrics are coherent. They're reproducible. If you run the calculations again about trickle-down economics or whatever we're doing, then it tells you that everything's healthy. They're not valid because they're not capturing the reality of people's lives, what's important and what they use money for. You can see these same things in education and psychology and all of the soft sciences. like we talked about in the last episode. And here's the thing, you feel this, whether or not you notice that you feel it.
而这些指标是连贯的。它们是可复制的。如果你再次运行关于涓滴经济学或我们正在做的任何事情的计算，它会告诉你一切都很健康。它们不是有效的，因为它们没有捕捉到人们生活的现实，什么是重要的，以及他们把钱用在什么地方。你可以在教育、心理学和所有软科学中看到同样的事情，就像我们在上一集谈到的那样。这就是重点，你感觉到了，无论你是否注意到你感觉到了它。
The same reason why the grand scale of the soundtrack of a movie works. It influences your feeling whether or not you were aware why. Which David Bowen might like that analysis of watching a film. But we've been convinced that the solution is inside the thing
就像电影配乐的宏大尺度起作用的原因一样。它影响你的感觉，无论你是否意识到原因。大卫·玻姆可能喜欢那种观看电影的分析。但我们已经被说服，解决方案就在那个
that no longer works. And then if we just tweak the model and we adjust the variables and we get better data, clothes, that the problem is technical, not fundamental, and definitely not beneficial to the system not working. And that the mirror can just be polished until it reflects the territory accurately. You know, that's the trap that I talked about before, but now I'm talking about the feeling. Last time was literally what's happening.
不再起作用的东西里面。如果我们只是调整模型，调整变量，获得更好的数据，衣服，问题是技术的，而不是根本的，绝对不是系统不工作带来的好处。镜子可以被擦亮，直到它准确地反映领土。你知道，那是我之前谈到的陷阱，但现在我谈论的是感觉。上次是字面上正在发生的事情。
And this time is the subjective, how it feels. The mythical, the poetic dimension. The uncanny, you know, Freud's ummelik. is the experience of something familiar that has become strange, something that should feel like home, but it doesn't anymore, something that should feel normal or feel safe or feel good, that we're telling ourselves does, but we know that it doesn't really. It feels wrong. We're living in a world that looks functional, that institutions are operating and the metrics are being produced, but the procedures being followed doesn't result in the thing that they are
而这次是主观的，感觉如何。神话的、诗意的维度。怪异的，你知道，弗洛伊德的“ummelik”，是某种熟悉的东西变得陌生的体验，某种应该感觉像家，但不再是了的东西，某种应该感觉正常、安全或好的东西，我们告诉自己它是，但我们知道它实际上不是。它感觉不对。我们生活在一个看起来功能正常的世界里，机构在运作，指标在产生，但遵循的程序并没有产生它们
supposed to produce. That's an uncanny valley. And so this dual language problem, how does it fit into that? Because when people try and articulate the wrongness, when they say, the metrics don't match my life, the economy isn't actually good, I don't feel safe, the institutions aren't actually helping. They get dismissed. They're being emotional. They're not looking at the data because there's so many escape valves built into the way that we create truth now.
应该产生的东西。那是一个恐怖谷。那么这个双重语言问题，它如何融入其中？因为当人们试图表达这种错误时，当他们说，指标与我的生活不符，经济实际上并不好，我不觉得安全，机构实际上并没有提供帮助。他们被驳回了。他们太情绪化了。他们没有看数据，因为在我们现在创造真理的方式中内置了太多的逃生阀。
They're letting their feelings override their facts. But their feelings are data. when the experience is information and the felt sense of wrongness is the territory trying to communicate through the noise of the map. We're all dissociating and we're all going through this dissociative split, you know, at a collective level. And, you know, again, there were moments like this before, you know, in the 60s and 70s. Leary's, you know, turn on, tune in, drop out. It was this response to leave those systems, man, they're not real anymore and we're not going to participate in them until they come back to us. And Leary wasn't entirely wrong.
他们让自己的感觉凌驾于事实之上。但他们的感觉就是数据。当体验是信息，而这种错误的感觉是领土试图通过地图的噪音进行交流时。我们都在解离，我们都在经历这种解离分裂，你知道，在集体层面。而且，你知道，再次强调，以前也有过这样的时刻，你知道，在60年代和70年代。利里的，你知道，“开启、调频、退出”。这是对离开那些系统的回应，伙计，它们不再真实了，在我们回到我们身边之前，我们不会参与其中。利里并不完全错误。
You know, the Vietnam War was built on lies and consumer society that. We talked about, you know, Bernays' role in that, Florence, grandson, and all of this stuff was not good. But when they left, so there was this idea that they weren't going to participate in the metrics of success, the suburban house, the stable job, the nuclear family. You know, they weren't making people happy. Something was wrong and people could feel it. So they turned on and expanded consciousness and they dropped out of the system. that seemed so broken and they believed, you know, where they were building this alternative by not participating.
你知道，越南战争建立在谎言和消费社会之上。我们谈到了，你知道，伯内斯在其中的角色，佛罗伦萨，孙子，所有这些东西都不好。但当他们离开时，有一种想法是他们不会参与成功的指标，郊区的房子，稳定的工作，核心家庭。你知道，它们没有让人快乐。出了问题，人们能感觉到。所以他们开启并扩展了意识，退出了那个看起来如此破碎的系统，他们相信，你知道，他们通过不参与来建立这种替代方案。
What happened was they lost, they maybe won the culture war, and then they lost everything else, which will just lead you to become co-opted because they must have the mythic for the literal. The New Age movement is good at doing that. Western esoteric magic sometimes is good at doing that, the people that espouse those types of goals, you know, as a collective solution. You know, the material structures, the distributions of the distributions of power, the economic arrangements, those didn't change. And so your aesthetic will be co-opted
发生的事情是他们输了，他们可能赢得了文化战争，然后他们失去了其他一切，这只会导致你被收编，因为他们必须拥有神话般的字面意义。新时代运动很擅长做这件事。西方秘术有时很擅长做这件事，那些拥护这些目标的人，你知道，作为一种集体解决方案。你知道，物质结构、权力的分配、经济安排，那些没有改变。所以你的审美会被收编，
because it's something that they can take from you. Um, you know, by the time Reagan took off in the 80s, the counterculture had been fully absorbed into the consumer economy. And, you know, it thought it was opposing something, but it was just being taken over. Rebellion became a marketing strategy and authenticity became a brand and the symbolic victory had been captured and neutralized, like this happened over and over again. But I'm seeing, saying is I do think one of the benefits of consciousness right now, or you know, this sort of collective consciousness is that people aren't willing to fall for that again. And so there's sort of this stalemate where people have a whole lot of power and other people know that they haven't
因为这是他们可以从你那里拿走的东西。嗯，你知道，当里根在80年代上台时，反文化已经被完全吸收到消费经济中。而且，你知道，它以为自己在反对什么，但它只是被接管了。叛逆成为了一种营销策略，真实性成为了一种品牌，象征性的胜利被捕获并中和了，就像这种情况一次又一次地发生。但我所说的是，我确实认为意识目前的好处之一，或者你知道，这种集体意识，是人们不愿意再次上当。所以存在一种僵局，人们拥有很多权力，而其他人知道他们没有，
and they don't like it, but no one's really doing anything because the old solutions were sort of arriving at the fact that they don't work anymore. How do we navigate a world where individual identity is constantly being assimilated into a massive memetic hive mind? You know, I'm not not going to do an episode on anime like a lot of people have requested or at least not yet, but like if you are writing me about Neon Genesis Evangelion, yes, I do think that this sort of collective merging and the terror of it is what a show like that is about. If you don't know what that is, um, moving on. Um, you know, the dream time, like I talked about in the beginning, you know, it's, this is the useful framework, I think, because it comes and where that comes from,
他们不喜欢这样，但没有人真正做任何事情，因为旧的解决方案在某种程度上得出了它们不再起作用的事实。我们如何在一个个人身份不断被同化进大规模模因蜂巢思维的世界中航行？你知道，我不会像很多人要求的那样做一集关于动漫的节目，或者至少现在不会，但如果你写信给我关于《新世纪福音战士》，是的，我确实认为这种集体融合及其恐怖是像那样的节目所关心的。如果你不知道那是什么，嗯，继续。嗯，你知道，梦幻时代，就像我在开头谈到的那样，你知道，它是，我认为这是一个有用的框架，因为它来自哪里，以及它来自哪里，
and again, you can read more about this on the blog if you want is, Aboriginal Australians and they have that concept. They had this idea that the dream time was really their, you know, cosmology. They weren't Gnostics and that they were like, the material world is fake and we weren't born here and we'll go back to something else. They also didn't, they didn't completely reject it, but they didn't completely embrace it either. What they did was they made the entire world, this liminal space,
再次强调，如果你愿意，可以在博客上阅读更多关于此的内容，是澳大利亚原住民，他们有那个概念。他们有这个想法，梦幻时代确实是他们的，你知道，宇宙学。他们不是诺斯替教徒，他们不是说物质世界是假的，我们不是出生在这里，我们会回到别的地方。他们也没有完全拒绝它，但他们也没有完全拥抱它。他们所做的是让整个世界，这个阈限空间，
where both things converged. And the place where they overlap the most heavily in this diagram was the dream time. The goal wasn't to overcome the material and, you know, go into the spiritual world or, you know, reject the spiritual and live purely in the material. It was to bridge them together. You know, the literalism of the material and the spiritualism of the oral and mythic world, you know. And so because the dream time was an attempt to do that, and I'm talking about the metamodern, and that's why I think that it's a good metaphor for this moment. Like, Gnosticism was a metaphor for last thing that I described. No. You know, it's on the last episode. You know, the dream time is this eternal symbolic realm that, you know, it interpenetrates ordinary reality at every moment. And the ancestral beings who created the world and all of the ancestors who were the thing that got me here are still with me and I'm participating with them in a mythic pattern that shapes existence and is still shaping it. And time isn't a line moving from past to future. It's this depth dimension.
两者都汇聚的地方。在这个图中重叠最严重的地方是梦幻时代。目标不是克服物质，你知道，进入精神世界，或者，你知道，拒绝精神并纯粹生活在物质中。而是将它们连接在一起。你知道，物质的字面主义和口头与神话世界的精神主义，你知道。所以因为梦幻时代是尝试这样做，而我谈论的是后现代，这就是为什么我认为它是这个时刻的一个好隐喻。就像，诺斯替主义是我描述的上一件事的隐喻。不。你知道，它在上一集。你知道，梦幻时代是这个永恒的象征领域，你知道，它在每一刻都渗透进普通现实。创造世界的祖先存在，以及所有作为让我来到这里的祖先，仍然与我在一起，我正在与他们参与一个塑造存在并仍在塑造它的神话模式。时间不是一条从过去移动到未来的线。它是一个深度维度。
There's a, it's not time like a timeline, it's time like a time less. And in the dream time, you know, individual beings are not separate isolated entities. There, we are all collective. We're all the same. We're nodes on a vast web of kinship that extends to animals and plants and to the land itself. And yeah, Christian mystics like Meister Eckhart, you know, they went here. So do Hindus with concept like Andresnet, or many of them, or many parts of Hinduism. so do
这是一种时间，不是像时间线那样的时间，而是像无时间那样的时间。在梦幻时光中，你知道，个体生命并非孤立存在的实体。我们是一个整体。我们都是一样的。我们是广阔亲缘网络上的节点，这个网络延伸到动物、植物，乃至大地本身。是的，像迈斯特·埃克哈特这样的基督教神秘主义者，他们触及了这一点。印度教徒也是如此，比如“不二论”的概念，或者印度教的许多部分，也是如此。
you know the Buddhism in some ways Mahayana and Taravada both have you know a conception of this but I'm asking you to say that the internet is kind of our new dream time because the phone is the way that we are connected
你知道，佛教在某些方面，大乘佛教和小乘佛教都有这种概念，但我是在请你承认，互联网在某种程度上是我们新的“梦幻时光”，因为手机是我们与世界其他地方连接的方式。
to the rest of the world now and I mean this sort of literally you know if the internet is creating a collective organism a massive interconnection connected neural network or hyperneural network. We're all a part of it. But what it's experiencing now is growing pains. It's in a developmental crisis. It's becoming a teenager. The brain is forming when it hasn't really found coherence. And like we like to tell our teenagers, it should probably
现在，我的意思是，从字面上看，如果互联网正在创造一个集体有机体，一个巨大的互联神经网络或超神经网络，我们都是其中的一部分。但它现在所经历的是成长的烦恼。它正处于发展的危机中。它正在变成一个青少年。大脑正在形成，但还没有真正找到连贯性。就像我们喜欢告诉我们的青少年那样，它可能应该
drive careful and it probably shouldn't drink. This is what a neurosis looks like from the inside. You know, conflicting impulses, fragmented identity, the sense that different parts of yourself are at war with each other. anxiety without a clear cause, depression without a clear reason, the feeling that something is deeply wrong but you can't articulate what? The collective brain is experiencing all of this and we feel it individually because we're part of the collective. Our individual anxiety is in part the anxiety of a larger organism working through these
小心驾驶，而且可能不应该喝酒。这就是神经症从内部看起来的样子。你知道，相互冲突的冲动、支离破碎的身份、感觉到自己不同的部分在相互交战。没有明确原因的焦虑，没有明确理由的抑郁，感觉有什么地方出了大问题，但你却说不清楚是什么。集体大脑正在经历这一切，而我们作为集体的一部分，也感受到了这一切。我们的个人焦虑在某种程度上是更大的有机体在处理这些
contradictions and sitting with these tensions. And this could be interpreted as a call for despair, but I'm not despairing. You know, the problem is systemic, but the solution is systemic too. You know, the metamodern condition is sometimes described as an ice oscillation or swinging back and forth between the sincerity of modernism and the irony of postmodernism, you know, the literality of communication and also its symbolic function. But we're really trying to contain both, you know, to have a tension between these opposites. And we do oscillate. We reach for grand narratives and we see through them. into ironic detachment and then we yearns for something real, or, you know, more fulfilling.
矛盾并承受这些紧张关系时的焦虑。这可能会被解读为绝望的呼唤，但我并不绝望。你知道，问题是系统性的，但解决方案也是系统性的。你知道，元现代状况有时被描述为一种振荡，或者在现代主义的真诚与后现代主义的讽刺之间来回摆动，你知道，交流的字面意义及其象征功能。但我们确实在试图容纳两者，你知道，在这些对立面之间保持一种张力。我们确实在振荡。我们追求宏大叙事，然后又看穿它们，进入讽刺性的超脱，然后我们又渴望某种真实的东西，或者说，更令人满足的东西。
But back and forth, neither position is stable. And the oscillation is not an end state. It's a phase. The pendulum swings until it finds this new echolibrium, or it's not a pendulum. The fused brain doesn't have to be a monster. The collective organism doesn't have to be pathological. And the dream time doesn't have to be a nightmare. But whether or not it becomes something beautiful or something terrible or something just more,
但来来回回，没有一个位置是稳定的。这种振荡不是最终状态。它是一个阶段。钟摆摆动直到找到新的平衡，或者说它不是钟摆。融合的大脑不必成为怪物。集体有机体不必是病态的。梦幻时光也不必是噩梦。但它是否会变成某种美好的东西，或者某种可怕的东西，或者某种仅仅是
human or sort of the in a cycle of both of those things we contain we contain both um you know it depends on how we navigate the transition we have to kind of endure attention we have to find some way to clean up collective trauma and we have to learn to sit with uncertainty to step into the unknown with some kind of more than scientific and also more than spiritual faith in something in ourselves in a in a future that is bigger they're better than this for a long time the parallel objectivities could stay separate. You know, your reality is over there, and their reality is over there, so go where you belong.
人类的，或者说是处于两者循环中的东西，我们包含了两者，嗯，你知道，这取决于我们如何驾驭这种转变。我们必须忍受这种张力，我们必须找到某种方法来清理集体创伤，我们必须学会与不确定性共处，以某种超越科学也超越精神的信念，踏入未知，相信某种东西，相信我们自己，相信一个比现在更宏大、更美好的未来。很长一段时间以来，平行的客观性可以保持独立。你知道，你的现实在那边，他们的现实在那边，所以去你该去的地方。
In different populations inhabiting different worlds, each, you know, internally coherent, each reflecting its own assumptions back to itself. In these bubbles floated alongside of each other without touching, and the mirrors faced their own mirrors and reflected indusely. You could go your whole life without seriously confronting the fact that other people live in a completely different factual universe from you. That's one of the things that I want to be real clear is not new. But those bubbles couldn't stay separate forever.
在居住在不同世界的不同人群中，每一个，你知道，内部都是连贯的，每一个都将自己的假设反射回自身。这些气泡并排漂浮，互不接触，镜子面对着自己的镜子，无限地反射。你可能终其一生都不会认真面对这样一个事实：其他人生活在一个与你完全不同的事实宇宙中。这是我想明确指出的一点，即这并不新鲜。但这些气泡不可能永远保持独立。
The crises that we face are now too large to be contained in a single bubble. Because these things are starting to collide based on the way that we've hypernetworked the world. And we can't hide from each other in the way that we used to be able to, based on where we went in our free time and who we talked to. That's why I'm calling this a collided. scope. You know, these parallel realities that could coexist through mutual avoidance and being forced together now, and they're grinding against each other like gears that don't mesh. You know, their teeth that don't fit, they're mechanisms that are clashing. And the
我们现在面临的危机太大了，无法被限制在一个单一的气泡中。因为基于我们对世界进行超网络连接的方式，这些事物开始发生碰撞。我们无法再像过去那样，根据我们空闲时间去哪里以及和谁交谈来躲避彼此。这就是为什么我称之为“碰撞镜”。你知道，这些可以通过相互回避而共存的平行现实，现在被迫挤在一起，它们像不啮合的齿轮一样相互摩擦。你知道，它们的齿不吻合，它们的机制在冲突。而
whole apparatus is kind of shuddering until it figures out a new way to run, a new type of lubricant. You know, in a kaleidoscope, mirrors create beautiful patterns, and they reflect fragments into symmetry. But what happens when the mirrors themselves start moving, when they're no longer fixed in place, but they're sliding and crashing and breaking, the pattern shatter and the fragments collide and the reflections become collisions. And that's where we are. The separate realities can't stay separate, and the material world won't let them go, and the crises are too big, too fast, too indifferent to respond to our constructions, and a lot of times we don't even notice them until they're gone. The 24-hour news cycle has become a 24-second news.
整个装置都在颤抖，直到它找到一种新的运行方式，一种新的润滑剂。你知道，在万花筒中，镜子创造出美丽的图案，并将碎片反射成对称。但当镜子本身开始移动时会发生什么？当它们不再固定在原位，而是滑动、碰撞和破碎时，图案破碎，碎片碰撞，反射变成了碰撞。这就是我们所处的境地。独立的现实无法保持独立，物质世界不会让它们离开，危机太大、太快、太冷漠，无法回应我们的构建，很多时候我们甚至在它们消失之前都没有注意到它们。24小时新闻周期已经变成了24秒新闻。
cycle. You can feel this in every conversation that goes wrong in every, you know, place where you feel disconnected from things like family or communicating or therapy or medical things or art or community spaces that just either aren't there or don't feel right anymore. You know, this grinding is painful and it's disorienting and it feels like the end of something. But here's what grinding does. It wears things down that don't fit and removes the parts that don't make the thing run. Grinding does make things fit back together. And the parallel realities have to come back together somehow.
周期。你可以在每一次出错的对话中，在每一个你感到与家庭、交流、治疗、医疗、艺术或社区空间等事物脱节的地方感受到这一点，这些空间要么不存在，要么感觉不再合适。你知道，这种摩擦是痛苦的，令人迷失方向，感觉像是某种事物的终结。但摩擦的作用是这样的：它磨损了不合适的东西，去除了那些让事物无法运行的部分。摩擦确实让事物重新契合在一起。而平行的现实必须以某种方式重新融合。
Because we have to find things that we all think are self-evident, that we all agree on again. Even if we can't agree on how things work, we need to start by agreeing on what the goals are. This is kind of a brittle hope, you know, a brutal hope, you know, living in this collision. The bubbles were never sustainable. The parallel objectivities were always a temporary condition, so what comes after the collision? The separate perspectives that we've had have been reflecting each other for decades now. You know, building power before they collide at potential energy. In a mirror facing a mirror, each one is confirming its own assumptions by seeing them reflected back.
因为我们必须再次找到我们都认为是自明的东西，我们都同意的东西。即使我们不能就事物如何运作达成一致，我们也需要从就目标达成一致开始。这是一种脆弱的希望，你知道，一种残酷的希望，你知道，生活在这种碰撞中。气泡从来都不是可持续的。平行的客观性一直是一种暂时的状态，那么碰撞之后会发生什么？我们所拥有的独立视角几十年来一直在相互反射。你知道，在碰撞之前积累力量，处于势能状态。在面对面的镜子中，每一个都通过看到自己的反射来确认自己的假设。
But reflection without contact is just narcissism. It's each bubble admiring its own. constructed reflection. And the collision breaks the narcissism. It forces contact with what's outside. We may have lost the ability to be as avoidant as we wish we could be. You know, the metamodern condition isn't just oscillation anymore. It's collision. And the poles were swooned between. They're crashing together. And in that crash, something is going to give. A kaleidoscope is turning, and the mirrors are moving, and the patterns are shattering. And what we build from these fragments is the new picture. And I hope it can hold us. I hope it can hold us really tight.
但没有接触的反射只是自恋。这是每个气泡在欣赏自己构建的反射。而碰撞打破了自恋。它强迫与外部事物接触。我们可能已经失去了像我们希望的那样去回避的能力。你知道，元现代状况不再仅仅是振荡。它是碰撞。我们摆动的两极正在猛烈撞击。在那次撞击中，总会有所妥协。万花筒在转动，镜子在移动，图案在破碎。我们从这些碎片中构建的东西就是新的图景。我希望它能容纳我们。我希望它能紧紧地容纳我们。
And I hope it can make us feel safe. The biggest stuff that I see is the recognition that trauma treatment is self-evidently necessary. But before that, that we are traumatized, we're being traumatized by this. It's not a luxury. It's a foundation. It's a right. And because trauma fuels the blind spots, it makes these things worse. It makes us less. likely to ever solve them. Trauma is why we built the bubble. Trauma is why we defend representations that don't connect anything real. The collective organism is sick, it's traumatized, and the parallel realities, the grinding gears, are these responses groaning at collective scale. We have to learn how to actually live together, not to manage each other,
我希望它能让我们感到安全。我看到的最大问题是认识到创伤治疗是显而易见的必要。但在此之前，我们受到了创伤，我们正因此而受到创伤。这不是奢侈品。这是一个基础。这是一项权利。而且因为创伤助长了盲点，它使这些事情变得更糟。它使我们更不可能解决它们。创伤是我们建造气泡的原因。创伤是我们捍卫那些与任何真实事物无关的表象的原因。集体有机体病了，它受到了创伤，而平行的现实，那些摩擦的齿轮，就是这些在集体规模上呻吟的反应。我们必须学会如何真正地生活在一起，而不是互相管理，
not to avoid each other, actually live together. In Western history is largely the story of how we managed avoiding parts of self even when we had to live in proximity. Connection without internal avoidance, that's the task. You can't connect with others unless you understand, you know, the parts of yourself and you can't face, you know, parts of yourself that you can't tolerate. Internal avoidance has become external avoidance. We need to see ourselves as multiplicities, not unified selves. It was always a fiction.
而不是互相回避，而是真正地生活在一起。西方历史在很大程度上讲述了我们即使在必须近距离生活时，是如何设法回避自我的某些部分的。没有内部回避的连接，这就是任务。你无法与他人连接，除非你理解，你知道，你自己的部分，而且你无法面对，你知道，你无法忍受的自己的部分。内部回避已经变成了外部回避。我们需要将自己视为多重性，而不是统一的自我。那一直是一个虚构。
We need to stop splitting through. emotion. We can hold our own multiplicity. The parallel realities are not just political. They're psychological, and the external fragmentation mirrors the internal fragmentation. You can't fix one without addressing the other. The internal system is the external system. That's what the collective brain metaphor of the dream time gives us. You know, what we build from these fragments depends on whether we can finally stop avoiding ourselves. Avoiding reality itself because the parts of ourselves or the parts of other people that we don't like are just there. And they're just there like it's raining outside or they're just there that like there's a mountain in your way.
我们需要停止通过情绪进行分裂。我们可以保持自己的多重性。平行的现实不仅仅是政治性的。它们是心理性的，外部的碎片化反映了内部的碎片化。如果不解决另一个，你就无法修复其中一个。内部系统就是外部系统。这就是梦幻时光的集体大脑隐喻给我们的启示。你知道，我们从这些碎片中构建的东西，取决于我们是否最终能停止回避自己。回避现实本身，因为我们不喜欢的部分，或者我们不喜欢的人的部分，它们就在那里。它们就在那里，就像外面在下雨，或者就像你面前有一座山一样。
It doesn't matter what you think about it. It doesn't matter what you feel about it. Those things are real. We didn't choose this. But the collision is happening whether we want it or not. And the only question is whether we participate consciously. whether we bring the witness consciousness, the dual, language fluency, the shamanic navigation to the collision, or whether we just get ground up in the gears because we refuse to see reality, inside of us and inside of other people.
你怎么想并不重要。你怎么感觉并不重要。那些东西是真实的。我们没有选择这一点。但无论我们是否愿意，碰撞都在发生。唯一的问题是我们是否自觉地参与其中。我们是否将见证意识、双重语言流利度、萨满式的导航带入碰撞，还是因为我们拒绝看到现实——我们内心和他人内心的现实——而仅仅被齿轮碾碎。
That's where it always was. Build a bridge. It's never stayed. It's with you here. Yes, I've gone away. Stories ever stay. Please ever stay. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它一直都在那里。架起一座桥。它从未离开。它就在这里与你同在。是的，我离开了。故事永远存在。地方永远存在。此集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。